رمضان كريم اذا اعاده الله علينا وعليكم
باليمن والبركات سنكون معكم في سياق مسائل
عربيه برمضان عبر المدن فهكذا نبدا اليوم
مساء العربي هذه الصفيان من مكه المكرمه
رينادويهي من طرابلس
ونداحجازي من ام الدنيا من عاصمه مصر
القاهره نبدا من القاهره معك ندى كيف تبدو
اجواء رمضان في اليوم الاول من الشهر
الفضيل
صباح الخير يا سهام صباح الخير يا نادين
هو احنا بادئين يعني الفقره مع الاذان
بتاع المغرب اهو الحقيقه احنا دلوقتي الجو
في اول يوم بيكون طول ما فيهوش زحمه كتير
ناس ههه لا طولوا براحتكم بس هو اول يوم
ناس بتفضل اكتر ان هي تفطر في البيت مع
الاسره وكده وبعدين احنا كمان عندنا طقوس
يعني اول يوم ده بيكون في محشي بيكون في
بط بيكون في جلاش لحمه مفرومه فالحاجات دي
احنا كمصريين بنفضل اكتر ناكلها من ايد
امهاتنا وجدتنا اكثر من المطاعم فهتلاقي
اول يوم كده الجو هادي خالص والدنيا اهو
يا ندى كمان احنا دايما بنعرف ان مصر من
البلدان العربيه لتعد احد ابرز البلدان
العربيه لتظهر عليها مظاهر الاحتفال وطقوس
الاحتفال خصوصا في فتره السحور على كل حال
في موضوع ثاني كمان حابين نسمعه منك الى
جانب الاجواء الرمضانيه قانون الاحوال
الشخصيه الجديد اللي هو محور جدل دائ م
خلال السنوات الماضيه شو عم بيصير يا ندى
عندكم
هو فعلا حديث الناس كلها دلوقتي هو قانون
الاحوال الشخصيه الجديد او تعديلات اللي
في قانون الاحوال الشخصيه
المتوقع ان هو يقلل كتير من نسبه الطلاق
في مصر واللي فيه اكتر يعني من
صلاحيات كمان مديينها للقاضي علشان يتدخل
في الحالات السريعه لدعم الاسره علشان
يخاطب جهه العمل بتاعه المطلق ويقدر ان هو
يعرف دخله ويحدد النفقات فيها كتير من
التنظيم كمان بين الطرفين اللي بيتجوزوا
يعني فيها الزام اختار من الزوج لو هو
هيجوز على زوجته الاولى فيها
توثيق للطلاق زي ما في توثيق للزواج علشان
برده يقلل شويه من الطلاق الشافعي
والمشاكل اللي بتحصل منه
العقد نفسه بتاع الزواج والطلاق هيكون فيه
شروط تنظم العلاقه علشان الدنيا تكون
واضحه ما بين الزوجين اكثر يمكن حاجه كانت
مثيره للجدل بين الناس وفيها مع وضد هي
منع الاب الرافض لدفع النفقات انه يشوف
ولاده يعني في ناس كانت شايفه انه لا هو
في الاخر ده حق الطفل ان هو يشوف ابوه
سواء بقى هو دفع نفقه او لا وفي ناس كانت
شايفه انه طالما الاب مش بيصرف عليهم فهو
فعلا مش من حقه ان هو يشوفهم فده كان اكثر
حاجه مثيره للجدل في القناه مش هنطول عليك
يا ندا نخلي لك وقت في طريقي مادام الاذان
في مصر هلا ننتقل الى طرابلس والزميله
رينادويه تحدثنا عن الاجواء الرمضانيه في
اليوم الاول من رمضان في الشارع اللبناني
وعن تحولات الخارج اهلا بك يا رينا طقوس
رمضان في لبنان هذه المره عارفين عليها
[موسيقى]
نعم مساء الخير ورمضان كريم لكم جميعا
يعني في لبنان ورغم الازمه الاقتصاديه
الخانقه والركبه السياسيه المتتاليه
وانهيار الليره وغلاء المعيشه الى ان
الناس هنا مصرون على التماس بهجه العيد
والامل بقدوم شهر رمضان فقد اقدم المئات
ليلى امس هنا من امام معرض رشيد كرامي
الدولي في طرابلس على اطلاق الاف المناطيد
المضيئه التي زينت سماء المدينه ورسمت
البهجه على قلوب ووجوه الكثيرين اما الان
فانا في واحده من الموائد الرمضانيه التي
تقام يوميا في هذه المكان ذات طرابلس
الخيريه تطعم اكثر من 2000 شخص يوميا
وتطلق ايضا معها مبادره على اهميه اعاده
التدوير وفرز النفايات ومدار البلاستيك
واود ان اشير الى انه في طرابلس وفي هذا
في اول يوم من رمضان يعني يحرسوا الناس
على تقديم سفره من البياض يعني ان يطغى
اللون الابيض على ماكولاتهم على المائده
في اول يوم من رمضان لما يعكسه الابيض من
تفاؤل وامل وصف اما بالنسبه
فانها يعني تشبه حال البلاد الزينه
متواضعه جدا وبسيطه خنقت يعني خنقتها ازمه
الكهرباء ولكن يعني
البهجه في قلوب الناس الذين ينتظرون على
مدار العام هذا الشهر الفضيل رغم رنا
اليوم ونحن نتابع معك جديد الاخبار من
لبنان حول وضع رمضان في رغم الظروف
المعيشيه والاقتصاديه الصعبه الى اننا لا
يمكن ان نتجاوز الجانب الاحتفالي مظاهر
الاحتفالات بدخول الشهر الفضيل على
اللبنانيين اليوم هل من جديد فيما يتعلق
بمبادرات المغتربين مثلا
نعم المبادرات يعني في لبنان على مدار
العام بسبب هذه الاوضاع الاقتصاديه الصعبه
والتعاضد الاجتماعي ياخذ اشكالا كثيره الا
ان يعني اموال المغتربين وخاصه في هذه في
هذه الفتره يعني يعول عليها المغتربين
اللبنانيين في افريقيا وفي اوروبا وفي
الدول العربيه يرسلون اموالا الى الجمعيات
التي تعنى بتوزيع حصص غذائيه ووجبات
للافطارات هناك ايضا يعني مبادرات محليه
انا قمت بجوله في المدينه القديمه قبل ان
اتي الى هنا يعني طبعا الناس كلهم
استوقفون للقول كم عن غلاء اسعار الخضار
والفاكهه والسلع الشراعيه الشرائيه ولكن
هناك سيده قالت لي انه على الرغم من كل
ذلك هناك بركه في النفوس يعني قالت ان
الخضرجي قدم لها اليوم بعض الحبات من
الفاكهه واخبرني اخرون ان هناك شخص تكفل
على نفقته الخاصه باناره كل شوارع المدينه
القديمه واحيائها الشعبيه اذا يعني
المبادرات لم تعد خلفيه على احد
والمغتربون هم ايضا يعني لم يعد خفيا انه
عليهم عول اللبنانيون وبفضلهم يمكن
صمد اللبنانيون لفتره طويله خلال هذه
الازمه
شكرا كيرينا وننتقل الى مكه المكرمه وهاني
نصفيان مراسم مساء العربيه هاني اهلا بك
نرسم معك الاجواء في الحرم المكي في اول
ايام الشهر الفضيل تسمعني يا هاني
نعم اهلا بك
طيب شكله
مهما تغير الزمان ومهما تغير المكان ولكن
يعني تبقى بشاشه نادين وسهام مستمره في
البرنامج الجديد والاطلال الجديد
هذا الامر اليوم راح عنه
هنا من صحن المطافي الحرم
والكثافه العديديه للمعتمرين في اول يوم
رمضان طبعا زميلتين او زميلتان يعني كانوا
يخبرونا عن
ابرز ما يقومون في في سواء في القاهره او
كذلك في لبنان لكن هنا الوضع مختلف هنا
العباده هي التي تسود المكان في الحرم
المكي حيث الطوائف والسعي للمعتمرين هم
دائما يحرصون ان تكون عمرتهم في في رمضان
بينما كاميرا مساء العربيه هي تتجول وترص
ايضا اجواء هنا للمعتمرين سوف اخذ معي
مقابله احد المعتمرين ولكن نتعرف على اسمك
السلام عليكم احمد اني من العراق اهلا
وسهلا فيك يا اخوي احمد يعني هذه اول عمره
لا لا الحمد لله جاي قبل يعني كثير يعني
عشره عشرين مره كثير يعني من 2018 على طول
اجينا والان يعني ما شاء الله يعني اجواء
جدا رهيبه واحنا نحب اول شيء كل عام وانتم
بخير كل عام وانتم بالف خير ان شاء الله
اسال الله ان يعود عليكم وعلى جميع
المسلمين رمضان مبارك الاجواء جدا جميله
واني بالنسبه الي احب اوصل صوتي بان اشكر
اداره المسجد الحرام واشكر كل الناس
القائمين على راحته امن الحجاج لان حقيقه
يعني كانوا مبدعين العفو المعتمرين
والحجاج لان التنظيم على اعلى دقه امانه
يعني من كل
بمنك يتكلم عن اعلى دقه يعني رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين الجهات تتحدث انه سخرت الخدمات
لكن انت كنت في 2018 بديت العمره والان وش
تشوف الاختلاف والله اشوف الاختلاف انه
الاعداد يعني ما شاء الله احنا ما حج يعني
ما شاء الله انا جاي الحاج على 19 يعني
قريبا الاجواء من اجواء الحج والسهوله
والمرونه والدخول والله لا لا ميه ميه
حقيقه تنظيم جدا انا ليش الحقيقه اللي
استوقفني انه انا حبيت اسوي وياك لقاء في
سبيل اوصل صوتي بالشكر لاداره شكرا شكرا
اذا هذا هو حديث احد المعتمرين هنا طبعا
بس بشكل سريع طبعا الرئاسه شؤون الحرمين
هنا في المسجد الحرام وفرت اكثر من 12 الف
شخص يخدمون هؤلاء الحجاج اليوم رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين هي تطمح بان يصل عدد معجبين في
شهر رمضان الى اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين حاج
بخلاف السنوات الماضيه او بخلاف ما كانت
او كانت ايام العمره قبل ازمه كورونا التي
كانت تصل مليون ونصف الى مليوني وما اجمل
ونحن نشاهد هذه المشاهد التي تاتينا
مباشره من مكه المكرمه وتحدثنا ايضا عن
الخطه وهي اكبر خطه تشغيليه في تاريخ
الحرمين وسط توقعات ايضا بتدفق الملايين
من المعتمرين نحن نشاهد في ساعه مساء
العربيه الاخباريه هذه الصور والمشاهد
المباشره من الحرم صحيح نعم
شكرا يا هاني صور خاصه الان نلتقطها
لمسائل عربيه وشكرا لكم